[Music]
memory is everything
without it we are blind
[Music]
without it we lead the plate of our
world to chance
[Music]
i'm sorry to disturb you thomas but i've
just received troubling news tell me
what is it it's grindelwald
her time is closed my brothers and
sisters our wall with the knuckles
begins
today
the world as we know it is coming on
them
if we're to defeat him
you'll have to trust me mr kowalski we
need you said it one and i don't want
out
you do know i'm a witch right
dumbledore said i give you something
jacob
this is the team that's going to take
down the most dangerous visit in a
century
who wouldn't like our chances
[Music]
oh
no one can know everything
not even you
what are you doing is madness
with or without you i'll burn down their
world
dangerous times
favored dangerous men
if by tea time all of us are still alive
we should consider our efforts a success
mr kowalski my pleasure
[Music]
we really intend to turn you back on
your own kind
was you said we could reshape the world
even if we make mistakes
we can't try to make things right
[Applause]
[Music]
we're gonna need some help
[Music]
there's nothing you can do to stop me
[Music]
things are not quite what they appear
[Music]
i trust you're enjoying your wand mr
kowalski
can i keep this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
without you i'll burn down their world
no
if we don't stop it
always been the spinning shaking you
brilliant man you know me pal i can't
pass up a good poor kid
to save our world each of us has a role
to play
if by tea time all of us are still alive
we should consider our efforts a success
[Music]
thank you
correct three points to hufflepuff
he's not here for you he's here for me
i drew my wand which was even more
foreign
if you listen carefully enough
the past whispers to you
we're here to see i was dumbledore
that would be my brother
the world as we know it is coming up
then
[Applause]
if we're to defeat him you'll have to
trust me
[Music]
this is the team that's going to take
down the most dangerous wizard in over a
century
a major zoologist his indispensable
assistant
wizard descended from a very old family
the school teacher
and
a muggle
dumbledore said i give you something
jacob
are you kidding me right now
who wouldn't like our chances
i have to save the world are we
things are not quite what they appear
[Music]
swivel but delicately
i'm swiveling out yourself
[Music]
oh whoa
what is this place
the room we require
[Music]
correct three points to hufflepuff
[Music]
very dangerous it's very powerful i've
gotten wrong hands you know
mess you up where did you guess it
the out for christmas
[Music]
you